[Music]
paul is with us in jackson mississippi
hey paul how are you
doing all right man how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
well i've come into a
a predicament here that um a lot of
people don't don't get the chance to do
um here in about four months i'm going
to be receiving a check for about 1.2
million dollars wow um
where'd
um a
[Music]
a land deal
okay so you you had a piece of land that
you sold and it's gonna you're gonna net
you 1.2 million
well actually it's sort of like a
finder's fee i found some land took it
to a developer
um it was worth a lot of money um and
he's going to turn it around
so that's going to be my percentage of
the profit wow very nice okay
i hate it when that happens good job
if you find any more let me know
absolutely okay
how can we help but yeah um i'm i'm 27
i have about 50 000 in debt
um
and taking in this kind of money
it's great but it's also kind of scary
because i don't know what to do
well that's a lot of wisdom
it's why it's wise to be scared if you
were
strutting around acting like you knew
what to do and you'd never done it
before that would be the first sign
you're going to lose the money so
um really good really good position to
take a healthy kind of fear not not
toxic fear not being anxiety ridden or
something but uh just going ah this
scares me a little bit like this is a
really powerful car and i'm not that
great a driver yet
right yeah
cool
so
should i should i
i don't own a home right now um i'm
renting should i
should i take
um
i don't know 200 000 and put it down on
a house
or should i mean
should i reinvest this money or you know
and i have a i have a day job as well
all this
side income that i have is is working
from
4 30 to 10 o'clock at night and on
saturdays and sundays wow not a bad side
hustle
yes i know i've always been really
driven
um and i'm so what do you make a year on
your day job
70 000 okay and you're used to living on
that
oh yes okay all right well you can do a
lot of different things paul um i'll
give you a couple of things that uh
first let me throw some just basic ideas
at you and then i'll throw some
conceptual ideas at you as well okay
basic idea is um write a check pay off
the debt
okay
okay you said you had 50 000 in debt
right
yes sir okay so you write a check and
you pay off the debt that's thing one
thing two is you need to sit down with a
good tax pro
and calculate what the taxes are gonna
be on this and then just set that aside
and pretend like it's not yours because
it's not yours
you're gonna get in a pinch if you start
screwing around with a portion of this
that is taxes so just set aside an
account over there and be ready for next
april when it rolls around
uh and hold on the money long as you can
hold on to it but just put it in a money
market account and pretend like you
don't own it anymore
and that's going to be substantial
amount of money
i figured it would be around 250. yeah i
think probably 30. i think it's probably
300. yeah but sit down with your tax pro
and calculate it exactly and set that
aside okay
and then that tells you what you got to
work with okay so let's call it 300 and
then let's uh call the other 50 and that
gets us down to 8.50
okay correct um and
what would you if you were going to buy
a home do you want a house
you know not necessarily not not in the
market that it is right now i don't want
to pay
you know i don't want to pay 300 000 for
a house that's worth 170. uh honey it's
worth 300. it's not worth 175.
okay it's not coming back down
okay the real estate prices have
retreated in the history of the united
states never
okay long term well that makes me a
little bit more comfortable i mean we
had one retreat in the 30s and it came
back up we had another retreat in the 08
and it came back up and those are the
only two times it ever went backwards
and it came back up uh and so we're not
we're not going to see a retreat in as a
result of this mess we're in right now
but we are going to see a slowing in
growth so but you're a single 27 year
old guy you may not want to screw with a
house you may want to get you a nice
condo or you have to mess with stuff
right i don't know what your living
situation is but i would go pay cash for
a residence
okay
whatever that is and so let's call that
300 that still leaves you 550 laying
around
what are you driving what are you
driving
um i've got a uh
2018 f-250
okay okay that's where all my dad is
okay oh that's that's the truck okay
should you pay off the truck keep the
truck that's a great car keep it okay
what's your solution well beyond that i
mean you can always park extra money in
a high-yield savings account and use it
towards your next goal so i love the
idea of getting a reasonable residence
let's pay off all the debt let's put
let's get our emergency fund in place so
set aside maybe you know 20 30k over
here for that and beyond that look at
what your next goals are maybe you want
to do real estate investing and you want
to pay cash for that maybe you want to
go on some vacations
maybe you want to set it aside because
you don't know what's going to happen in
the next five years maybe you meet
someone you get married and so i like
the idea of parking a lot of this aside
once we have our house paid for
yeah nothing wrong with that at all
here's the thing if you want to deal
with the fear like sometimes i talk to
someone that's inherited two million
dollars or something and they're like i
don't know what to do i don't know
anything about money
and so uh you know we put them through
financial peace university immediately
which we're going to do for you okay i'm
going to pay for you to go through it
because i want you to get the basics on
handling money down and then you kind of
build yourself a little board of
directors for this million dollar
business
and the board of directors is a good
insurance agent
a good estate planning attorney that
helps you get a will in place
a good tax tax professional in your
corner
uh sounds like you already know a lot
about real estate uh but you may you
know if you want to put a real estate
person in your corner that's fine but
you put some experts around you that
will teach you different things that you
need to know
to be able to do things that you don't
know how to do
my for instance my estate plan is very
complicated
there's no possible way i could have
invented with my knowledge base my
estate plan
so i have paid an estate planning lawyer
a lot of money
to keep my family from having to pay
tens of millions of dollars in taxes
after i die
because they tax you twice in the u.s
now because if you're rich you must be
evil and you should be punished
so um
but the uh you know that's an example i
don't do my own taxes
uh and i i could probably muddle through
but i probably missed some stuff i don't
pull my own teeth either so
um you know that that's the thing you're
dealing with so you know you kind of get
some advisors around you so that you've
got and you don't have to pay them
anything they're just there and you
develop a relationship and get maybe a
good maybe meet with one of the
smartvestor pros about investing in
mutual funds you may want to take that
half million and you may be a real
estate guy that wants to do some deals
and just do them all with cash
and you can't mess them up if you're
doing them with cash
uh because there's i've never seen a
single piece of real estate in my life
go to zero
uh and you know it's not it doesn't it's
not bitcoin i mean it can't go to zero
so uh you know if you want to buy a
piece of land and you want to fool with
it flip it over you want to buy property
and flip it
or you want to buy some properties that
create income that's all okay
good news about jackson mississippi it
is a reasonable real estate market
uh much more so than a lot of areas of
the country so um a lot of stuff you can
do there you got a lot of options
congratulations sir it's amazing very
proud i want this to set him up for the
future he's 27. and if he manages this
money well he's going to be able to
retire early do whatever he wants to do
well i mean if you invest a half a
million dollars and you made 10 percent
that's 50 000 a year that's not bad you
know and you got taxes on that and other
stuff and it won't be 10 of your every
year but you can make 10 averages but he
can about replace his income if he
investigates get real close and if you
left it alone
you know it'll double every seven years
so in seven years he's 27 when he's 34
if you know he'd have a million
and uh so when he's 41 he'd have two
million wow
and just just off of that that's
incredible that's you know something to
think about yeah but you know that that
but again that's investing it in mutual
funds leaving it alone
if you're gonna fuel real estate you can
probably make more than that but you got
more hassle and expertise involved